I took this task
from the exercises of the Cannes Academy.
It reads: "Arrange the following expressions
from the smallest to the largest with the coordinates
of the rectangle below. "
So we have to find what y, z and x are.
Then we have to arrange them.
Let's first look at,
well let's take a look at y.
And this is a little confusing,
because the variable t is used
to present the coordinate x,
to represent the x coordinate of this point.
Let's see if we can find it
what is the x coordinate of this point.
This is a rectangle.
The x coordinate of this point here
will be the same as the coordinate x at this point.
They lie on the same vertical line
in the way they are painted.
If this has the same x coordinate of x equal to four,
then this will have the x coordinate of four.
And now we use the variable y for the coordinate x,
which is a bit strange,
but this would be the point of coordinates four and seven.
So y equals four.
Now let's see what we can find for z.
Ok, z is your coordinate for ...
let me use another color here,
z is the coordinate y for this point.
But which other point has the same y coordinate?
Ok, it will be on the same level,
I suppose we can say so,
in a vertical direction.
It will lie on the same horizontal line.
Therefore, it will have the same coordinates as this point.
This point has a y coordinate equal to three.
So this point, its coordinate will be three,
or we can say that z equals three.
So it will be equal to three.
Last, but not least,
we have to find out how much x.
And x is the coordinate x.
Let me do it in a different color.
x is the x coordinate for this point.
Okay, this x coordinate will be the same
such as the x coordinate for this point here above,
which is equal to two.
They lie on the same vertical line.
They both lie on the line,
x equal to two.
So x will be two.
It is the coordinate x and also the variable x.
Therefore, this will be two.
So if we want to sort them from the least to the greatest,
x is the largest.
Then we go to, this is actually the opposite
of what we have here.
x, then z and then y.
Two, then three and then four.
Actually let me see the exercise
and just check the answer.
So, x is the smallest,
then z is in the middle
and finally y is the largest.
We can check our answer.
We've got it right.